you ready yeah we're good
[Music]
while we were shooting swagger
the world changed
in 2020 people really started to lean in
and ask themselves why there's certain
things in the country that happen in the
way that they do that they've been
happening for such a long time there was
a lot of social issues that arose during
the pandemic when things paused and
things shut down and the social issues
came into play reggie put those at the
forefront because they were things that
he wanted to show that we weren't scared
to talk about i can't breathe
i really had to ask myself you know do i
want to deal with this but it just
really occurred to me that this was
another opportunity to hold the mirror
up to
to society
[Music]
the ability to add current events into a
show to make them more powerful you know
they hit a little closer to home the
stuff that goes on in our everyday lives
we need to see even though it's a tough
conversation to have what we speak on in
the show are things that
young people are going through all over
the country that are unseen and it will
mold you or it will break you
our kids go out of town and are
confronted
by racism something wrong officers we
got called about a disturbance we're
just a basketball team on the way to our
game we're gonna need to see your ids no
matter if you're a star basketball
player you work a regular job that stuff
may happen to you we wanted to see
what would happen if they had different
points of view about how to address the
issue what would you want me to do brawl
with him we should have told him that we
weren't scared i was scared
are we allowed to
in this country
still have different points of view and
still be american what happens if
someone takes a knee during the flag
and other people have different points
of view are we
allowed to love this country and
challenge it what does it matter it
matters no it doesn't talking about
brotherhood you find you if i stand
it's not going to change how you all see
me
how you all treat me
reggie put into us a responsibility as
performers to
be a voice for the voiceless
and uh to inspire people to be better if
people can't hear you you can't change
them and they weren't trying to hear us
scream loud enough and they'll hear us
scream loud enough and they'll hear six
foot four and black i think we did
what's right when we wrote all of that
into the series and this is the dialogue
that we need to have as a country to
speak on things like police brutality or
the pandemic in general and how it
affected people it makes what you're
doing honorable inspiration is the most
powerful thing that we got
on the planet in this day and age in
this time
what it means to grow up black in
america is a question that we need to
ask
and i think our show will not give all
the answers but ideally it will provoke
the right questions
i want to get the audience at the edge
of their seat
and while they're leaning forward hit
them with the truth
[Music]
you